PROFESSOR: --we'll start off
with a little review, so you
might chance it.
We're in the middle of
the chapter nine on
convolutional codes.
Today, I intend to hand
out problem set six.
I believe Ashish will have
it when he gets here.
And we'll hand it
out at the end.
Last time, I introduced you
to a lot of things about
convolutional codes and
their encoders.
I stressed that a convolutional
encoder had two
distinct characters.
One is it's a linear
time-invariant system.
So we can use the linearity
and time-invariance and
algebraic analysis of
convolutional codes.
Secondly, I stressed that's it's
a finite state system,
because it's a finite memory
system where each memory
element has a finite number of
possible values, over F2 or
indeed over any finite field.
And therefore, we
can use that for
different kinds of analysis.
We use that, for instance, in
conjunction with linear
property to find the minimum
distance to a particular code.
And we'll see that that's the
key to getting an efficient
optimal maximum likelihood
decoder --
is the fact that we only have
a finite number of states in
this system.
All right, so along the way I
kind of went all over the map,
as far as the introducing
various algebraic quantities.
I focused particularly on
formal Laurent series.
And I want to just give you a
little table to make sure you
have fixed in your mind what all
these different kinds of
sequences we're talking
about are.
On the left side, I have
Laurent sequences.
These are semi-infinite
sequences that must
start at some time.
Their delay is not equal to
minus infinity, which would be
if it were all 1's forever.
But their delay is
some finite time.
It could be negative,
could be positive.
That's their starting time.
And then they could
go on, possibly,
infinitely into the future.
And then, among those, we can
look particularly at the ones
that start at time 0 or later,
whose delay is 0, or whose
delay is non-negative.
These are called the formal
power series, and you've
probably encountered
them earlier.
They're a lot more frequently
encountered
in mathematics algebra.
The rational sequences are
simply those that can be
written in a very finite way as
a numerator polynomial over
a denominator polynomial.
Because the formal Laurent
series form a field, every
element is invertible, and, in
particular, every polynomial
has an inverse, which, unless
the polynomial is a monomial,
is going to run on for an
infinite length of time.
But nonetheless, there is a
subset, a countable subset of
these sequences that we
can write in this way.
And we call these the rational
sequences, and they're
analogous to the rational
numbers in the real field.
And their particular
characteristic, as we showed,
is that they're eventually
periodic.
And it's easy to see that these,
too, form a field.
Obviously, the inverse of
N of d over D of d is D
of d over N of d.
Provided that n of d is not
equal to 0, the denominator is
always required to be non-zero
for a rational sequence.
So that's a very nice subset.
It may or may not have
operational meaning.
Certainly, when we're
talking about
realizations, it has meaning.
And then the finite sequences,
by eventually periodic, I will
from now on include
the finite case.
If we have a finite sequence,
then its end is all 0's, and
that's certainly a periodic
sequence.
So I would say a finite
sequence is
also eventually periodic.
But among the rational
sequences we have,
particularly the finite
sequence, these do not form a
field, because the non-monomial
polynomials
cannot be inverted.
So these are merely a ring.
However, D has an inverse.
Over here on this side, D minus
1 has an element of all
these things.
D has an inverse.
Over here, on the causal side,
these are the causal analogs
to all of these.
In the case of causal rational,
we don't have
particularly good notation.
We just say these are the ones
that are both causal, formal
power series and rational.
But they are important, because
we've seen that it's
this kind of sequence that you
can get as the impulse
response of a time-invariant
linear system that is
realizable.
Realizable has two parts.
One is the impulse response must
start at time 0 or later,
by physical causality.
Two, the impulse response must
be eventually periodic,
therefore rational, if it's
going to be realizable with a
finite number of memory
elements.
So we include that in our
definition of realizability.
So these are sometimes called
the realizable sequences, or
the realizable D transforms.
And these, of course, the causal
finite sequences are
the polynomials.
These include the polynomials,
which are trivially easy to
realize with shift registers,
as we saw in our example.
So that's just a review of
all these quantities.
Does anyone feel the need for
further elaboration or
explanation?
Or can we go forward
with this?
We tend to use all of them as we
go along, so I want you to
have them clearly in mind.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why was
the [INAUDIBLE]
uncountable?
What was the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Why is that
uncountable?
Try to count it.
I could put it in one-to-one
correspondence with a set of
all binary expansions of the
real numbers, and that's an
uncountable set.
Some of these side comments are
just to trigger analogies
in your mind, maybe make it more
reasonable, what we're
talking about.
OK, so next.
Just again, to continue a quick
review, we talked about
realizable linear time-invariant
systems.
First, we talked about single
input, single output.
I'm imposing an order that
didn't necessarily exist.
In any case, these are
characterized by impulse
response, g of D, which, for
realizability, that implies
that g of D is causal
rational.
The fact that it's rational
means that we can write g of D
as n of D over d of D. And the
fact that it's causal, well,
we would always reduce this to
lowest terms in the first
place, so there'd be no point
carrying along common factors
in the numerator and
denominator.
By inserting enough powers of D,
we can make sure that both
of these are polynomials.
So if n of D, d of D are --
we can ensure that they're
actually polynomials, not just
finite sequences.
And if it's going to be causal,
that means that
we can always --
if we remove common factors
of D, that means that the
numerator might still have
factors of D in it, but the
denominator can't have
factors of D in it.
You see that?
Because, once we shift all these
over as close to 0 as we
can, the denominator has
to be closer to 0.
If D0 equals 1, that means 1
over d of D is something that
starts at times 0.
We multiply times
the numerator.
In order to have the whole thing
be causal, the numerator
has to be causal, because a
point I didn't mention, when
you multiply formal Laurent
sequences, their delays add.
If a of D and b of D are
Laurent, then the delay of a
of D times b of D, defined as a
convolution, is going to be
the sum of the delays of each
of the component sequence.
You just take the lower order
term on both and that's what
determines the lower order term
on the convolution, just
like in polynomials and
analogous to degrees.
So from this, we find that we
can always write a causal
rational sequence in this
form, if it isn't 0.
If it is 0, we just take n of D
to be 0, and d of D to be 1.
And that satisfies
this form, too.
I guess I didn't even have
to make that comment.
We're already in that form.
You can convince yourself this
is a unique way to write a
causal rational sequence.
And every other way is just
multiplying the numerator and
the denominator by some common
polynomial or finite sequence.
So now we had a little theorem
that says that, if g of D is
causal rational, and therefore
equal to n of D over d of D in
this form, then realizable with
how many memory elements?
Does anyone remember?
nu equals the maximum
of the degrees.
And I debated whether to
actually do this in class, and
I think it's worth taking a
few minutes to actually do
this in class.
It'll also appear as the
first homework problem.
So this'll be a little head
start on the homework.
So anybody have any ideas how
we can do this realization?
What we want is a circuit with
an input, u of D. Eventually,
an output, y of D equals u of
D times n of D over d of D.
For these are both polynomials
and D0 equals 1.
A lot of you have probably seen
this in discrete-time
linear filters.
It's going to be just
the same technique.
But if we don't have volunteers,
I don't want to
waste time.
The key is to use --
we're of course going to need
feedback in general.
To have a d of D, in general,
will not be 1.
If it's not 1, then we're
going to get an infinite
impulse response.
To get an infinite impulse
response, we need feedback.
So we're going to need some
feedback term in here.
And here is the motivating
idea of the construction.
We want to create something
here, v of D, which is
basically equal to u of D over
d of D. If we can do that,
we'll be done.
I'll show you why.
So we created a different
sequence, which is u of D
divided by d of D. And then we
pass that sequence through a
shift register.
And what do we get at
the various stages
of the shift register?
Here we would get v of D delayed
by one time unit, v of
D delayed by two time units,
and so forth, up to --
let's make this nu.
I want to realize it in nu
memory elements, where nu is
the maximum degree of either of
these defining polynomials.
So finally, out here, I
get d nu of D, v of D.
Now, what's the trick?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Because
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: That is the idea.
What do we get if we take out
these various lines, which are
v of D, through d to the nu v
of D, and we make a linear
combination of them?
We're going to do this twice,
actually, once to form the
feedback, and once to
form the output.
For the feedback, let me not
take this into the linear
combination.
Otherwise, I'd get a loop
without a delay element in
that, and that tends not
to be well-defined.
So I want to take a linear
combination.
In general, by taking a linear
combination of these things, I
can get the multiple of v of D
times any polynomial degree,
nu or less, just by taking
the coefficients of that
polynomial as my linear
combination.
Do you see that?
I'm not seeing people's --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: In the linear
combination
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
you also take the one with
zero derivative.
PROFESSOR: You're getting ahead
of me, which is fine,
but I'll ask for that comment
in just a second.
Let me first create
the output.
Suppose I had v of D equals u of
D over d of D. Then to get
the output, I simply want a
linear combination, which will
give me n of D times u of D over
d of D. And that would be
the correct output.
And since n of D is a polynomial
degree less than
nu, I can do that by simply
taking n nu times this, n nu
minus 1 times that, n2 times
that, n1 times that, and 0
times that.
And that will give me what I
want as an output, if I'm
successful in getting v of
D of this form here.
So let me try a similar
trick up here.
The trick is, I force d of D to
start off with a 1, to have
D0 equal 1.
So what I'm going to create
up here is the linear
combination, d of D minus
1 times v of D.
First of all, let's verify
that I can do that.
d of D minus 1 is what?
It's a polynomial.
Its degree is the same as the
degree of d of D. Now, if d of
D is equal to 1, if the
denominator is just 1, this
whole thing falls out.
I don't need anything
coming in here.
d of D is 1. v of D is equal
to u of D, so that's the
polynomial case where I
don't need feedback.
So let's assume d of D is not
equal 1, therefore it's some
polynomial of degree nu, degree
of d of D, which is
less than or equal to
nu, and so is this.
But by subtracting out the 1,
I have no constant term.
So it's going to be a multiple
of D. That's another way of
saying that.
It's going to have no constant
terms, so I only need to form
a linear combination
of these terms.
So I can do it.
Now, if I do that, let's just
solve this equation.
I create x of D. This is
supposed to be a plus.
This is supposed to be a minus,
to work over any field.
This trick works over real or
complex, or what you'd like.
x of D is u of d minus d of D
minus 1, times v of d, times x
of D. Maybe I should just
call this v of d.
Now I'm going to solve
for v of D.
So I actually have a v of D on
both sides of the equation.
This results in u of D equal
v of D times d of D. And
dividing both sides by d of D,
I see that I succeeded in
getting what I wanted.
So this is a typical trick of
realizing a rational impulse
response by including a feedback
loop and negative
feedback in your system.
This is done in the notes.
I'm surprised if you haven't
seen this before.
Maybe it's that people in
communications don't take
circuits courses, or they don't
take digital signal
processing courses.
Most people look puzzled.
In any case, can you agree that,
formally, I've shown
that we get what we want here?
So I've given a way of
realizing, given a causal
rational function, where nu is
defined is the maximum degree
of these two polynomials.
There's a realization with
nu memory elements.
A little bit more work, we could
prove that this is the
minimum possible number
of memory
elements for this system.
That gets into linear
system theory.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I mean, what I want
is down here, I want the sum
of n_i times d to the i, v of D.
So the linear coefficients
are going to be these n_i.
If I drew it out, I have
n0 here, n1 here.
So it's scalar linear
combination, over F2.
And what is that?
v of D is common.
That's just n of D times v
of D. Same trick up here.
Is that what was puzzling
everybody?
Think about it.
What is a linear combination?
Something that looks
like that.
The second part, let's
now talk about a
convolutional encoder.
And we're just going to talk
about rate 1/n in this course.
So this is a single input.
n output linear time
invariant system.
That's my definition, I guess,
of what I mean by a
convolutional encoder.
And when I say linear
time-invariant, I also want it
to be a realizable, in the two
senses that its impulse
response is causal rational.
So [INAUDIBLE]
down.
Now it's characterized by
n-tuple of impulse responses.
So it's going to be sum g of D
equal to g1 of D, up to gn of
D, where clearly all these have
to be causal and rational
in order for it to
be realizable.
If any one of them was not
causal or not rational, then
that individual impulse
response wouldn't be
realizable and the whole thing
wouldn't be realizable.
So where we have the gj of D
are all causal rational.
And now, again, I'm going to put
this into a standard form.
In general, this is going to
be n1 of D over d1 of D, so
forth, up to n_n of D over d_n
of D. So I'm going to have
different denominators for
each of the numerators.
But I can always put it into the
form, n1 prime of D over a
common numerator, d to D, and up
to n_n prime of D over d of
D. Let d of D be the least
common multiple
of all these d_i's.
These are all polynomials.
Least common multiple is
well-defined from our
discussion of factorization.
So I can always put in the least
common multiple here,
and then whatever d1 lacks out
of the least common multiple,
I multiply top and bottom
by both of that.
I have the same rational
function, now with a common
denominator.
So I'm always going to put
it in that standard form.
And then I will say this is
always realizable, with nu
equal now the max of
any of the degrees
that appears in here.
So let me just abbreviate that
by degree of the numerators,
which I'll just write as vector
n prime of D, or the
degree of the denominator d, of
the common denominator d of
D. Now, that's very
easy to see.
Why is that?
Can certainly realize
the first one here
just by doing that.
Yes?
If I want to just generate the
first output, I build a
circuit like this, and
I don't need more of
the new memory elements.
There might even be some
redundancy in that.
All right, so how would I
then realize the second?
Is it just me?
Nobody is volunteering
anything.
I've realized this.
Now I'd like to realize
a second output.
Now I want to realize this.
Make this n1 of D. I want to
realize n2 of D over d of D,
times u of D.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Just take out
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
So all I need is the second
linear combination.
So let me just make this
n linear combinations.
Then we're going to
have n outputs,
an n-tuple of outputs.
Then I can form each
one as a linear
combination of those up there.
I really like more of you
to be speaking up.
Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: There's a second
combination --
I mean the inquiry should
come [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but again, what
I want to realize, I have
all the delays of
v of D up here.
What I want to realize is n2
of D times v of D, which is
equal to that.
n2 of D is the polynomial
of degree less
than or equal to nu.
So I can do it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
parallel to that n1 D over d.
The --
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
I'm confusing you because
I put all these here.
I actually wrote out the
linear combination.
To say what I just said, I
really need to go back to my
original form, forget these
multipliers, do the
multiplications in here.
That's what I mean by the
linear combinations.
Now I'm OK.
The inputs are just
the shifts.
Make a linear combination of
them, that's the output.
So easy proof.
What's significantly harder to
prove in this case is you
can't do any better than.
There aren't any realizations
with fewer than nu, where nu
is computed by first reducing
to standard form and then
evaluating this.
That's the best you can do.
But we aren't going to go into
minimal system realizations,
linear system realizations
in this course.
I'll just insert it.
So this is how we can always
build a convolutional encoder,
whether it has feedback
or not.
And so whatever we come up with
as nu, this'll basically
determine the state complexity
of our decoder.
The state space is dimension
nu, is finite dimension.
And because we're over a finite
field, the actual
number of states is
only 2 to the nu.
Still can't get more than
2 to the nu states for
that system up there.
So we're still in finite
state world.
So in particular, it's finite
state realization.
And again, this is
if and only if.
If we have if and only if, we
have an n-tuple of causal
rational, or even a matrix
of causal rationals.
We can make a realization
like this.
So that's convolutional
encoders.
At least write 1/n over F2.
And now the next step was what's
a convolutional code.
And a convolutional code,
we defined as, given a
convolutional encoder, which
is just the set of impulse
response, given g of D, the
corresponding convolutional
code is just u of D, which is
single sequence times this
n-tuple of sequences, as u of
D ranges through all the
formal Laurent sequences.
Sequences that start at some
time in the all-zero state and
then continue perhaps forever.
It's very quick to
show that C, its
properties is it's linear.
Obviously, it's a vector
space over F2.
Multiplication by scalars
is trivial.
Addition is trivial,
so it's linear.
And its time-invariant, meaning
the shift of any code
sequence is another
code sequence.
If I have one particular code
sequence, and I want to see if
the shift of that is in the
code, well, that code sequence
must have been generated by some
use, so if I just shift
the u by the amount of time
that I want to shift the
output, y, then I'll get
the shifted output.
So it's easy to show that D to
the k of C is simply equal to
C for any integer k.
Actually, it just suffices to
show that the single time unit
shift is in the code, and that
implies all the rest of this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
We would want at least one of
the g_i of D's to start at 0.
Otherwise, they don't
cancel out, do they?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what you're saying is we
don't want d to be a common
factor of all the n of D's.
And that's true.
In fact, we don't want to have
any common factors of
all the n of D's.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The u we've
defined, so it can
start at any time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So notice that these
have separate algebraic
characters.
This is a Laurent sequence.
These are called causal
rational sequences.
So they have different
restrictions on them, but they
play together that way.
So where you're getting to is
this idea of code equivalence.
I can just keep going.
So code equivalence, let's
abbreviate it this way.
g of D and some other n-tuple,
g prime of D,
generate the same code.
We say that g of D generates
C up here.
So two different n-tuples
generate the same code, C,
which is our notion
of equivalence.
And we more or less proved last
time it is true that g of
D is some --
this is just a single sequence
multiple of g prime of D. So
we have to have a of
D not equal to 0.
Otherwise, I think there could
be any sequence there.
So what you were saying is that,
if all of these n's had
a common factor of d, then why
not just shift them all over?
And that would be the same
as multiplying --
suppose we had a g prime of
D where they all had d's.
Suppose we just multiply
them with d minus 1.
We're still going to get the
same code, but we're going to
reduce the degrees of
all the numerators.
And therefore, we're likely to
get a simpler realization.
And that's the track we're
going down right now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This would
only shift the n's.
I'm assuming that all the n
of D's are multiples of d.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the root of d, right?
So if you can reduce the d of
D you can't save anything.
PROFESSOR: You might not save
anything if you've got a
denominator, d of D, that
has a larger degree.
AUDIENCE: And that's
always the case.
PROFESSOR: No, it's not
In the general case,
either one of
these things can dominate.
In that picture we had, if we
have a low degree, d of D,
then it's only picking off of
these first elements up here.
AUDIENCE: But that definition
states [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is the maximum d and also
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we could have a big one here
making the outputs, and a
small one there going back.
In fact, we could have
d of D equal to 1.
Then we'd have no feedback
whatsoever.
So it could be either way.
But then given this code
equivalence concept, suppose
we have a d of D that
is very big.
Suppose it's dominated by
d of D. What would be a
good thing to do?
We have a certain code we want
to keep, but the nu, the
numbers for the dimension of the
state space is dominated
by the degree of d of D. So
suppose we have g of D equal
to n of D over d of D. And we
have degree of d of D is
greater than degree of n
of D. What would be a
good thing to do?
Why don't we just let g prime of
D be equal to d of D times
g of D, and that would
be just n of D.
So I'm going to convert from
the code generated by these
rational generators,
which are infinite.
I can easily just multiply out
the denominator, and now I
have a code generated just
by the numerator terms.
So it's feedback-free.
That may or may not be
important to me.
Actually, it turns out it's very
hard to make a case for
not having feedback, but it's
simpler, in any case.
We don't have this feedback
term in the encoders.
So we get a feedback-free
encoder.
And if this is true,
we may reduce --
we can certainly never
increase it.
But if this were true, then
we would reduce it.
If on the other hand, this were
less than or equal, then
nu would remain the same.
So that seems like that would
be a good thing to do.
So in fact, as I would advocate
as a first step, that
you clear the denominators,
and just come up with a
polynomial generator sequence
which generates the same code.
We're still going to have the
same minimum distance, the
same code sequence, the problem
from the decoder's
point of view is going to
be absolutely unchanged.
The decoder only cares what
the consequences are.
It wants to find the most
likely one that was
transmitted.
So let's not make the encoder
any more complicated
than we have to.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: nu doesn't change
in this condition.
nu does change in
this condition.
AUDIENCE: So we are always
better off multiplying by g of
D.
PROFESSOR: We can't
be worse off.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --or the same.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Got it.
All right, so let's now talk
about whether there's anything
we can do to n of D. We already
suggested that if all
the n of D had a factor of
d in them, why don't
just take it out?
Let's just write that down.
If all n of D have a factor of
d, then let's just transform n
of D to d minus 1 n of D.
So that reduces nu also.
And let's, of course, do that
as many times as we can.
So it's a good idea to take
out common factors of d.
We get a simpler encoder.
We're have a simpler
state diagram.
This leads us to a topic called
catastrophicity, which
is a misleading title because
you have no idea where I'm
going right now.
So I'm actually going
to try to fool you
for a little while.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
In the definition of code
equivalence, is there a
restriction [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that shouldn't be rational,
shouldn't be causal?
PROFESSOR: Should there be
a restriction on this?
Yes, of course.
It has to be rational
in order --
But that's a consequence.
If these are both causal
rational, then what does a of
D have to be?
It has to be rational.
It has to be non-zero.
And does it have to be causal?
No, in this case it's
not causal.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If there's a delay buried in g
of D, if everything starts at
time 1 or later, then a of D,
in fact, can be non-causal.
So the key restrictions are that
these two guys have to be
causal rational.
And that will tell you
restrictions on a.
Let me introduce this
by example.
And I'll warn you that
I'm going to try to
fool you for a while.
Let's just take a rate
1/1 encoder.
This may seem a little peculiar
to you, because it
has no redundancy, one
input, one output.
And I'm going to let g of
D just be 1 plus d.
So what do I mean?
I'm going to try to get some
mileage out of this encoder.
Here's u of D. Here's y of D,
equals 1 plus d times u of D.
Now let's draw the state diagram
for this encoder.
It's only got two states.
One is 0.
If we get a 0 in, we of
course put a 0 out.
We get 0, 0.
Or we could get a 1 in.
In which case, we would
get a 1 out.
Sorry, that was just
a single output.
And go to 1.
If we're in the 1 state,
and we get a 0 in,
then we get a 1 out.
Whereas if we get a 1 in, then
they're both 0, and we get the
complement.
So with the 1, we get a 0 out.
So that's the state transition
diagram of this encoder.
Now, let's go through a similar
kind of argument to
what we went through to find
the minimum distance was 5.
This is a linear system, so we
want to find the minimum
non-zero weight of
any code word.
And here's my argument.
There's a gold star to the first
person who punches a
hole in it.
Any code word, you have to
start in the 0 state, so
you're always going to get at
least one unit of distance
when you go to the 1 state.
You can stay out here as long
as you like, but eventually
you have to come back
to the 0 state.
And at that point, you're
going to get
another unit of distance.
So I claim the minimum
non-zero weight is 2.
Is that correct?
Let me try to create
some doubt.
What is the code here?
The code is the set of all
multiples of 1 plus d times u
of D, where u of D is a formal
Laurent sequence.
What is that?
I can write this briefly as
just the set of all formal
Laurent sequences
times 1 plus d.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
1 minus d minus d squared.
PROFESSOR: Good.
That's correct.
That's what's wrong
with my claim.
Let me detour around here.
Let me get an answer
to this question.
What is the code in this case?
It's the set of all possible
sequences you can get by
multiplying 1 plus d times the
formal Laurent sequence.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's just
the set of all
formal Laurent sequences.
Certainly for every formal
Laurent sequence, I can get
such a sequence this way.
In particular, the
code includes 1.
What do I need as an input to
get the output sequence 1?
AUDIENCE: String of 1's.
PROFESSOR: String
of 1's, right.
So an example, if u of D is
equal to 1/1 plus d, which is
a string of 1's, then y of D is
equal to 1 plus d times u
of D, which is 1.
1 plus d has an inverse,
and this is it.
So now we're coming back to
Mr. Aggarwal's point.
Suppose we put in u of D equals
this sequence, all 0's
before times 0, all
1's after time 0.
Then where will we go?
We'll go 1, and then
we'll just stay
in this 0 loop forever.
Anything wrong with that?
Is that a code word?
That is a code word, the way
we've defined the code.
If we had defined the code so
that the u of D were only
finite input sequences, then
this claim would be correct.
For any finite input sequence,
we eventually have to come
back to the 0 state.
So this is true for finite
inputs, not true
for infinite inputs.
So this is wrong.
The fact is d3 equals 1.
The minimum weight of
this code is 1.
But you see this is, first
of all, it's a confusing
situation for analytical
purposes.
Let me further indicate why
it might be bad to have an
encoder like this in general.
The key catastrophicity, in
general, will be defined as
there are finite outputs
generated by
infinite inputs, as above.
Or equivalently, there
are 0 loops in the
state transition diagram.
So by choosing a proper input,
you can just keep driving
around a 0 loop forever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the output is becoming finite,
so it's actually --
I'm just commenting on the
whole catastrophicity.
PROFESSOR: OK, well, I want
to next tell you where
catastrophicity comes from.
The opposite of this property
is non-catastrophicity.
What we want is non-catastrophic
encoders.
We want encoders where, to get
a finite output, you get a
finite output only from
finite inputs.
That's better analytically and
it's better in practice.
Here, let me draw you the
practical argument.
We have, for this particular
case, u of D comes in, gets
multiplied by 1 plus d.
That gives us y of D, which --
let me just abbreviate it.
We transmit that
over a channel,
and we get our decoder.
Actually, decoder doesn't have
much to do here, because all
possible sequences are allowed
at the output.
So if this were a binary
symmetric channel, the best
the decoder could do would just
be to put out whatever it
sees as its guess, y-hat
of D. So this
is the decoder estimate.
So in any case, this
can differ by
code words from that.
All possible code words
are possible.
And given y-hat of D, to get
back to u of D, what do we
have to do?
We have to divide by 1/1
plus d, in effect,
to invert this equation.
For y of D is equal to 1 plus d
times u of D, then the u of
D that corresponds to a
particular decoded code
sequence, y-hat of D, we get
by dividing by this.
But this is infinite sequence.
Suppose this makes
just one error.
It's possible for this to
transmit all 0's, and for this
to make just one error.
That's a code word.
That's a legitimate
code sequence.
So it's something the decoder
might come up with.
If it does that, then what's
this going to look like?
This is going to look like an
infinite number of 1's,
because this is the infinite
input that causes this code
sequence with a finite
number of outputs.
So it's precisely this
condition, whenever we make an
error that corresponds to a
finite output sequence, and we
translate it back to the encoder
input, that's an
infinite encoder input.
There's a one-to-one
correspondence between inputs
and outputs.
So it's got to happen whenever
we make that type of error.
And this is called catastrophic
error
propagation.
The decoder hasn't done
anything bad.
It made one error, as it's going
to do once in a while.
But the consequences
are catastrophic.
We make an infinite number of
errors in the bits that we
actually deliver to the user.
Now, of course, what's really
going to happen is that
sometime later the decoder
is going to make
another little error.
And at that point, this will
switch state again.
So that will terminate the error
burst when the decoder
makes another error.
But this is completely random.
It may take a long time
for this to happen,
and it's not good.
So for practical reasons, we
don't want catastrophicity.
I was going to give you another
example, but in the
interest of time, I'll
just write it down.
Here's another catastrophic
example.
Let me just do a rate 1/2
encoder so it looks more
reasonable.
And we'll make it look
very much like the
encoders we've had.
Our first example looks
something like this.
1 plus d squared.
I'll say 1 plus d.
So it's a feet-forward
encoder.
It looks perfectly reasonable.
The top channel is impulse
response, 1 plus d squared.
The second output has impulse
response, 1 plus d.
If you look at the minimum
weight for all finite
sequences, it's 4, not quite
as good as the other
one which had 5.
But is this catastrophic?
Yes?
Who said yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Great.
So the same observation, if u
of D is equal to 1/1 plus d,
which is, again, this infinite
sequence, then the output, y
of D equals u of D, g
of D, is equal to --
1 plus d divides both of these,
so we get 1 plus d1.
We get a finite output
sequence.
You saw that immediately,
because we know that
polynomials are divisible by 1
plus d if and only if they
have an even number
of non-zero terms.
So that's a more elaborate
example of where we can get
catastrophic behavior.
So what should we do here?
Clearly, we should divide out
the common factor from here.
We can do that.
If all of these polynomials
have a common factor, we
should divide it out.
And we know that the code
generated by -- if this is g
of D, we're going to say g prime
of D is equal to 1/1
plus d times 1 plus d
squared, 1 plus d.
And that is -- we've already
calculated --
1 plus d1.
So by doing that, first of
all, we got rid of the
catastrophicity.
Second of all, again,
we reduced nu.
So this is clearly a very
good thing to do.
So more generally, going back
here, if all n of D have any
common factor --
in other words, let's call --
I've used d, so what'll I use?
b of D equals the greatest
common divisor of all of the n
of D, 1 plus --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Who --
AUDIENCE: Do you think
it could be 1?
PROFESSOR: You're, once again,
30 seconds ahead of me.
So yes, that's what
I'm going to say.
If they all have a common
factor, then they have a GCD
that is not equal to 1.
That's if and only if.
So we're going to transform n
of D to 1 over b of D. We're
going to divide out the common
factor, n of D. That will be
our n prime.
And now what have we achieved?
We've achieved that there is
no common factor of these n
prime of D. So no common factor,
which does turn out.
So that will mean it's
non-catastrophic, and,
furthermore, will reduce nu by
whatever the degree of this
common factor was, degree
of b of D. Let me
write degree of GCD.
We want them to have
no common factor.
We want the greatest common
divisor to be 1.
Another way of saying this is
we want the ni of d to be
relatively prime, the nj of
d to be relatively prime.
And if that's true, then
can we prove that it's
non-catastrophic, that if we
have a finite output, that it
must've been generated
by a finite input?
AUDIENCE: No, because u of D
times n_i of D would have to
be a polynomial to be
catastrophic, and to get a
polynomial.
And u of D is rational.
It has something in
the denominator,
because u of D is infinite.
That denominator should
then get cancelled
out to one of these.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you have the
argument in your head.
Let me leave that as an exercise
for the student,
since at least a couple
of you see it.
The only way that you can get
this behavior, if you have an
infinite input which has in
its denominator a common
factor of all the n's.
So if the n's have
no common factor,
then this can't happen.
That's the outline
of the argument.
So what's our conclusion now?
Since we have multiple encoders
that generate the
same code, we'd like to get the
nicest one, in some sense,
as our canonical encoder
for a given code.
So we have a given code.
We can specify it by any causal
rational transfer function.
But then, having done that, we
should clean this generator
n-tuple up.
We should multiply out by the
least common multiple of all
the divisors to make it
polynomial, feedback-free,
possibly reduce nu.
And then we should check the
numerators and see if they
have any common factor, which
could be d or it could be any
polynomial.
And whatever it is, we should
divide that out.
And that will certainly
reduce nu.
So at the end of the day, we
have a canonical encoder,
which is equal to
g of D times --
we want to multiply by the least
common multiple of the
denominators.
We want to divide by the
greatest common divisor of the
numerators.
And this will be some n prime
of D, which will be
polynomial.
It will be delay-free.
That means it doesn't have
d as a common factor.
It will be non-catastrophic.
That means it doesn't
have anything
else as a common factor.
And it will have minimal nu,
for any encoder that can
generate that same code.
I haven't quite proved all those
properties, but I think
we're well along the way.
So this is really --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
There should be at
least n1 and n2.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, if we have a
rate 1/1 code, we just have
one of them, then what's the
greatest common divisor?
Suppose it's n of D over d of D.
The greatest common divisor
is n of D. The least common
multiple is d of D. We get 1.
So going through this exercise
for any rate 1/1 code, we'll
find that the canonical
encoder is 1.
And that is clearly what we want
for a rate 1/1 encoder,
because a rate 1/1 is always
going to have an out.
The code is just going to be the
universe code of all the
possible formal Laurent
sequences.
So we get down to the right
encoder for that code, not
some stupid encoder.
And in a similar way, going
through this process, we come
up with the right encoder.
Is this process unique?
Is there only one encoder
we could come up with?
Think about it a little, and
you could convince yourself
there's only encoder that you
can get from doing this.
This is over F2.
Over a larger field, it's unique
up to units again, up
to a non-zero scalar multiple,
which of course you can define
to be 1 and somehow
make this unique.
So it's basically a unique
canonical encoder that has all
of these properties.
You get it in this way.
So this is what we're
always going to use.
For instance, for our original
encoder, 1 plus --
what was it? --
1 plus d squared, 1 plus
d plus d squared.
Is that already in
canonical form?
This is irreducible.
This is divisible by 1 plus D,
so these are relatively prime.
It's feed-forward.
It doesn't have any denominator
terms, and it's
delay-free.
So it satisfies all of these,
and clearly you can't
manipulate it.
The only ways you're allowed
to manipulate it are by
multiplying by a of D over b of
D. And it's clear that if
you have a non-trivial numerator
or denominator, the
numerator will make it
catastrophic, the denominator
will make it to have feedback.
Now, as I was saying,
there's really
nothing wrong with feedback.
And so some people prefer --
the one thing that this doesn't
have, in general, is
it's not systematic.
That means the input stream is
not one of the output streams.
So given a canonical encoder
like this, can we always make
it systematic?
Yeah, we just divide by any
of these polynomials.
So here's an equivalent
systematic encoder.
For instance, if we divide
both of these by 1 plus D
squared, we get 1 plus
D plus D squared,
over 1 plus d squared.
This now is not polynomial.
It is delay-free.
It's non-catastrophic.
There's no 1 over something that
we can put in to get a
finite thing out.
It turns out it's still
minimal nu.
We know how to realize this with
two memory elements now.
And in general, if you're
not going to introduce a
denominator term that has a
greater degree than the
maximum degree of the numerator
terms, so it's still
realizable with minimal nu.
And so now it's systematic,
but now it's not
feedback-free.
So I consider this one
certainly the nicest.
The canonical feedback-free
encoder is the nicest one for
analytical purposes, for
instance, for trying to find
minumum-weight finite
code words.
Because of the finite property,
if we're looking for
the non-catastrophic property,
minimum-weight code words,
we only have to
look at finite inputs.
We can now use the kind of
analysis method that we use
that says you always have to
come back to the 0 state,
because only finite inputs can
produce finite outputs here.
This also has that property.
And people tended not to use
these for a long time, but it
was founded that in turbo codes,
you want to have this,
one of the generators
be infinite.
And it was also nice to have one
of them be systematic, so
that led to a revival of
interest in systematic
convolutional encoders.
And this, again, it's
a unique form.
If you say the first one has to
be the systematic one, then
there's a unique equivalent
systematic encoder that
generates any code.
So it's in alternative
canonical form.
Take your pick.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's systematic?
PROFESSOR: What's systematic?
Systematic means that the input
that's appear unchanged
as a subset of the
output bits.
For convolutional codes, it
means that one of the output
sequences, if you have a rate
1/n encoder, one of the output
sequences is simply equal
to the input sequence.
In other words, one
of the transfer
functions is equal to 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, very good.
Excellent comment.
Because now, if you have a
finite output sequence, in
particular you can just read
off the input sequence, the
information sequence, from this
first term, and if the
whole thing was finite,
it's finite.
So systematic directly ensures
non-catastrophicity.
Excellent, excellent comment.
Which you might try to prove
by the more elaborate
techniques that we had.
So that gets us pretty much
through the algebra that I
wanted to do.
Now I want to --
OK, good.
Now let's go more to the
finite state picture.
And our objective here is mostly
going to be to get to
Viterbi decoding algorithm.
But along the way, we'll see
that we can use something like
the Viterbi algorithm to compute
minimum distances,
too, once we have a finite state
picture to the code.
Again, take our example one,
where g of D is 1 plus D
squared, 1 plus D
plus D squared.
We have a state transition
diagram,
which looks like this.
And I won't bother
to label it.
And that's a complete
description of the encoder
operation, if I put labels of
inputs and outputs on all
these states.
So 0 slash 0,0, so forth,
1 slash 1, 1.
Just to draw the impulse
response, 0, 0, 1,
and 0 slash 1, 1.
There's the basic impulse
response going
around, like that.
Trellis diagram is
a very redundant
picture of the same thing.
We can start out in the
0 state that we like.
Let's say we start off in the 0
state at some time k, as we
always are.
We just don't know what k is.
Then let's spread the
state transition
diagram out in time.
Let's draw all the states
again at time k plus 1.
Actually, there are only
two it can get to,
at time k plus 1.
So we can either stay in this
state or we can go down here
to this state, at the
next unit of time.
I'm just going to keep drawing
all of the possible state
trajectories or paths.
At time 2, I can reach
all possible states.
0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1, 1.
Here again, I already
know what these are.
From here, I can
get 1, 0, 2, 0.
It goes with a 0, 1 out.
So 1 goes with a 1, 0.
And k plus 3, I now have all
possible transitions.
It's going to look like this.
Where can I go from 0, 1?
I can go back to here, or
I could go to here.
And I could label these.
I should label these.
But I won't.
Here, I can go to these two.
There are eight possible
state transitions.
k plus 4.
It's completely repetitive,
since it's a
time-invariant system.
I just keep going like this.
And why have I gone to
all this trouble?
This clearly contains the same
information as this diagram,
but it's just spread
out in time.
The basic reason for doing it is
that now there is a unique
trellis path corresponding to
every code word that can start
at time k or later.
So for instance, if I just have
an impulse at time k and
nothing else, then the unique
trellis path is this.
It starts at 0, goes through
two non-zero states, comes
back to 0, 0, and then stays
in 0, 0 forever more.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I've just taken an
arbitrary starting time, k.
After a while, I'll
just look at it --
well, it's entrained.
This is kind of the steady state
version of the trellis.
I've included a little
starting part here.
And if I terminated the trellis,
then I would also
have an ending time.
We'll talk about that.
So at this point, I just want
you to see what the trellis
diagram is.
It's basically just an unrolling
of the state
transition diagram
out in time.
And it allows me
to associate --
there's a one-to-one
correspondence now between
code words that start at time k
or later, and trellis paths.
So every one corresponds
to a unique, distinct
path through the code.
That's what we're going
to use in decoding.
Each of these paths represents
one possible decision that the
decoder could do about what
was actually set.
The decoder is actually going
to try to find the best of
these paths, in some sense, the
one that's closest to the
received sequence, in the
Hamming distance or Euclidean
distance, or likelihood sense.
Let's pause for a second, and
see how this could be used to
compute the minimum distance
of the code.
Let's assume that I have a
non-catastrophic encoder.
Then I know the finite sequences
are going to be
those that start in the 0
state, go through some
trajectory through the state
transition diagram, and then
ultimately come back
to the 0 state.
If I have canonical encoder,
I agreed what I'm
going to use now.
So one way of computing the
minimum distance would just be
to perform a search through
here, and try to find the
minimum detour, the minimum
weight detour that starts in
the 0 state, eventually gets
back to the 0 state.
It accumulates Hamming distance
along the way.
And that is the Hamming
distance of
some valid code sequence.
So here, it's not very tough.
And I've already gone
through an argument.
If you didn't know, you'd
say, OK, here's the
first one to look at.
This is the only one that gets
back in three time units.
Let's look for the finite path
that gets back to the 0 state
in four time units.
Again, there's only
one of them.
It looks like that, and it turns
out it has weight 6.
So this is, again, it always
ends up with a 1:1 when it
merges back in here.
And this, I think, is 0, 1
or something like that.
The only 0, 0 path in
here is this one.
But you can easily see the 0,
0 path doesn't form a loop.
You can't proceed down
0, 0 forever.
So I go through here, and I've
already got four units of
distance up to here.
In fact, I need to follow.
Next time I explore out here,
1, 1, 0, I've already got up
to four units of distance.
Now I know I'm always going
to have two at the end.
So any time I get to four
or more, I can stop.
And by that argument, I'm
already done when
I get to this one.
Or if I didn't want to use
that, I'd just explore --
I already know that there's one
of weight 5, the impulse
response, so I'd explore all
the possibilities out until
they accumulated at least weight
5, and assure myself
that there was no way of getting
back here with weight
less than 5.
And that would be a very
systematic way of evaluating
the minimum distance
to the code.
You can see you could do that
for any generators.
You with me?
Just explore this little graph,
picking up weight as
you go along.
That's basically the way the
Viterbi algorithm goes as
well, except what we do is we
have some received pair at
time k, r1 k, r2 k, r1 k
plus 1, r2 k plus 1.
We get two received symbols at
every time, whatever channel
we're going over.
Assuming that the channel is
memory-less, I get a some kind
of distance or weight or
likelihood weight at each
time, and maximum likelihood
sequence decoding amounts to
finding the sequence that's
closest, the code sequence
that's closest in Hamming
distance or Euclidean distance
or likelihood distance to the
transmitted sequence.
So I can simply put a metric
on each of these branches
corresponding to
what this was.
Now, if it was a binary
symmetric channel and I
received 0, 0, then I'd have
0 weight here, but weight 2
here, in terms of Hamming
distance from
the received sequence.
And similarly, as I go along,
I'd have another set of
metrics here.
If I received 1, 1, then this
one would have weight 2, this
one would be good, no distance
from the received sequence.
Each of these would have
distance 1 from
the received sequence.
So I get some kind of cost
for every path in here.
And then the decoding algorithm
is simply a matter
of finding the minimum
cost path.
You could all do that.
We just had a celebration for
Andy Viterbi out in USC, where
he's given them $50 million, so
they were very happy, and
had a great celebration.
And the thing he's best known
for is the Viterbi algorithm.
But what everybody knows is
that, once you reduce the
problem to this point, anybody
could have come up with the
Viterbi algorithm.
The Viterbi algorithm is just a
systematic way for trying to
find the lowest-cost path as
you go through a trellis.
And if you know dynamic
programming and it's obvious
how to do it, or even if you
don't, the next idea --
do we have a minute?
There's only one idea in the
Viterbi algorithm, which is,
when you get to this point,
you can already make a
decision about what the best
path is to get to each of
these states.
If the closest path over the
first three intervals is this
one, not this one, say, then you
can forget about this path
because it's never going to be
the first part of the ultimate
closest path, because we're
simply adding up independent
cost, independent increments.
So you can make a subdecision at
each of these states, what
the best path is up to that
state, the closest path.
And you only need to
remember that.
That's called a survivor.
And this was basically, Viterbi
was the first one to
put down this algorithm
with the survivor.
You can make interim
decisions.
You can only keep
the survivor.
Then all you have to do is
extend the survivor's one unit
of time out here.
Again, you have to add
the new metric.
You have to compare
the metrics to see
which one is better.
You select the survivor, and
once again, you've only got
four survivors going forward.
So you get an iterative
recursive algorithm that just
proceeds forward one unit of
time at a time, and keeps
finding the four best survivors,
or in general, the
2 to the nu best survivors at
time k plus 3, k plus 4, k
plus 5, ad infinitum.
And that's the Viterbi
algorithm.
So once you've drawn this
trellis picture, it's very
clear how you should decode, and
you get a very sufficient
decoding algorithm.
We'll come back next time.
I'll do that a little
bit more carefully.
I'll talk about terminated
codes.
I'll talk about how it works
when the code isn't
terminated, and I'll talk about
performance analysis.
But we're actually pretty close
to the end of chapter
nine at this point.